ciao ragazzi io scivolato
secondo me a furia di fare video così a
tirar su joe miller in braccio tipo john
cena siamo ritornati ragazzi oggi bella
tutti ragazzi scusate se la gente si
destabilizza siamo su a più oggi che
domenica la vedete uno scherzo episodio
che oggi volevo fare un episodio
speciale speciale insomma tutti i
livelli in specie con i fatti bene e
quelli della madonna e non jacques
pixelato ma bellissimo la sua volta sarò
una volta mi ricordo però il mio non mi
ricordo niente mamet pixel
ciao per dio
l'hack è male ma tu sorella mai fatto
benissimo a ciò anche la vita tra
l'altro posso morire
queste sono morti you suck come tono
hanno uguale alla prima si rischia di
fare allora presentata in attivo sta
roba e fighissima mi ricordo che una
volta ci riuscivo a farlo perché leggero
già l'avevo già fatto mille anni fa
merita di essere giocato da commentatore
della moneta a devo prendere le monete a
ok hai almeno mi sono sacrificato ma una
moneta l'ho presa da te bellissimo che
ogni salto fatto rumore qui ho a casa ci
siamo
bellissimo fatto veramente stava bene
con perfetto non avevo capito che potevo
farlo perché così bisogna che il salto
valido essere preciso perfetto
perfettamente sul fuoco e ora vado a
prendere la bistecca teoricamente
avrebbe risposto livello ci aveva messo
sei anni per farlo profilo
bellissimo bellissima sta roba dei pixel
fatto veramente bene bravo zio l'alba
dei morti viventi
va be water supply quindi delle riserve
dell'acqua destra va bene riserva
d'acqua armeria ho preso un fucile
qual è il tasto per sparare scusate ho
saltato e ha sparato però non penso sia
non era voluto poi non dovessi tenerli
mezzo alle gambe il fucile d'introd
andiamo avanti spara da solo bene si
farà con che cosa sta farà con cosa
premi che dilettanti non voglio saperlo
andiamo avanti ragazzi un fucile storto
però va bene anche così stiamo avendo
ancora spalla gli spara diete non so se
doveva andare esattamente così prevenuta
questa era veramente una cosa da zombie
vai avanti per tutto
mi sa che colora dovevo far fuori
davvero e non l'ho fatto fuori questa
settimana andrà avanti tipo zombie
finissimo ancora cioè più accurato di
residenti vostro gioco praticamente
allora tutta la gente morta così
fortissimo dato non sono zombie sono
tifo pallini verni non so se ve ne siete
accorti questo ci ha voluti sono i due
gol vi va bene
salve c'è un fucile a pompa in testa in
tutto questo salve grazie gentile
permesso posso entrare madonna che c'è
un paradiso
bellissimo beh non era così era bello ma
non era la classifica mondiale secondo
me però giocato 24 mila vini volte va
bene metro station al bellissimo di un
circolo station questa è la mente va
bene andiamo vediamo 4 funziona st metro
b è lamentato di happy meal ticket va
bene non fa niente
chiarissimo benissimo drink orange juice
c'è anche la pubblicità varata il
pubblicista
se fate fare i place metalli un cambio
dove l'ho mangiata lo mercato
chiarissime le direzioni raga mi fate
entrare che ho sbagliato sono entrato
incredibile ho messo un'ora ma sono
introdotti métro dopo salve
vado avanti non so neanche cosa dove sto
andando in realtà globale sto passando
ogni vagone della metro è fatta
benissimo occhio mi scusi beva un po gli
orange che abbiamo giusto testimonial
otello in ufficio e la città caotica
facciamo una città caotica buongiorno 46
milioni di volte ha giocato sony aveva
ben già già i bidoni sono fatti meno
della metà dei livelli male no portico i
bambini la prego
[Musica]
mi sa che non dovevo credere che però fa
niente cioè posso visitare sta città
magari con un altro personaggio di paul
padre gli yuppie che mi sembra più
adatto questa che questo genere di cose
che è successo qui turco demonio uno
struzzo
non avevo visto va bene e ragazzi c'è
uno struzzo che ci segue corrente fin
qua
scattavano ogni costo buongiorno è la
madonna cosa hai mangiato ieri fai la
cacca come le caprette che la fanno a
pallini con che tutto questo che vorrei
uscire di qua si può uscire dalla
finestra palo caso io perso allora cago
anch'io
va bene potevo andare solo fuori dall
altra finestra quindi devo rifare anche
difficile sto vivendo ci vuole skill
pensate come sia messi ma dei ragazzi
andiamo davanti non so cosa ci sia ma ci
sono altri piani vedo buongiorno
lavoriamo alla apple qui in questa roba
salve devo passare posso passare
gentilmente gentile no non possono farlo
però lo struzzo e caduto di sotto sono
contento ma posso andare avanti ok
perfetto sale che se la città incasinata
come che la chiamiamo quindi non è vero
madonna mai avrei pensato di essere
staccata da roma lo è di certo livello
sempre uno scherzo lo sto continuando
con il mio cuore ragazzi incredibile è
inciampata tipa o vabbè è stato carino
coltivarlo senza niente prove allora
perfetto per la palla
buongiorno a lei c'è un ufo steve è
appena diventato un alieno questo è il
livello più bello della mia vita fatto
pare non puoi ecco gli occhi guarda
copiamo lì per favore grazie
non so che il titolo il miglior livello
mai visto è già stato utilizzato in
molteplici volte ragazzi ma meritava
questa scena tantissimo su yoox
schiacciato da un meteorite e vale il
freddo e probabilmente miglior livello
di agris davvero
buongiorno gozzi e cibo o scambiato king
kong per godzilla prova bene serve
adesso qua ci sono zombie cioè da prima
che non c'era niente gli zombie
addirittura c'è proprio una trama in
questo livello
al centro c'è veramente consiglia ma non
ci credo ho previsto il futuro king of
the monster proprio va bene orco lo
schifo
corri
e stato bello sono super soddisfatto gli
studi livello grazie kirby paun age
world frozen caverne la caverna del
mondo ghiacciata
questa non l'ho capita all madonna che
testa tutto bene tutto ha poi commentato
e che mi servono davvero bene benissimo
tutto nella norma sono con nonno jacques
come se non ci fosse un domani sono
andato avanti con una velocità
incredibile prova niente
non badate a me che sono un vecchio
sulla propulsione aiuto non facevo
livello con non a ciò che da una vita il
problema è che è difficilissimo farli
con lui perché madonna cavata tantissimo
dai ero arrivato avantissimo dato il
livello è stato fatto è uno che si
chiama sono veramente annoiato si vede
prova rifarlo perché ho mancato la
piattaforma per ora andato bene fin lì
strano per essere io a giocare il solito
vanno molto male i miei livelli sono
morto mentre ho detto quella frase tra
l'altro geniale buono frena benissimo
benissimo teoricamente dovrebbe tenere i
razzi in atti perché rischio di
schiattare dove prova fa niente le gambe
non ti servivano neanche prima quindi a
posto a posto piano manoscritta allora
ascoltami se vai di propulsione già
potresti fare forze
forse ti prego ma si è chiuso il
passaggio come dai ce l'avevo fatta ma
per chi si è chiuso il passaggio portava
facevamo fatta per una volta che faceva
mente di gente sulle piste non posso
dire lo stesso è questa cosa allora
piano non è vero sono io sono vivo sono
arrivo va benissimo frena frena frena
per favore benissimo ciò non è vero
i ragazzi non posso fare questo livello
abete è bellissimo
ragazzi questo vale il video ho fatto
delle robe che non mi so spiegare
bellissimo sono orgoglioso di me stesso
sono tutti alti della mia carriera a
londra c'è chi aspira a fare cose dico
canzone io no
e so contento però devi togliere le
bombe dalla mia faccia benissimo ora
accompagna un po il movimento di sta
roba sono cadiamo benissimo per fare sta
parte ci ha messo un ora quindi ti prego
vinci non ti prego non tornerò mai più
quello il tuo libro
ma tu non la vedono solo di voi madonna
sarà vivo non so come va bene pian piano
piano per favore piano piano piano
benissimo non è vero sono caduto
elevator offline
poi parla zard offline va bene per ora
tutto a posto ma scrive shaun offline
che senso
e avanti diamanti io anzi vorrei che un
casino arrivati qua no le scale no a va
bene sono scandite chiusa pesantemente
non trovare neanche la perla impossibile
sia aperta permesso allora anche dove
sto andando ma ok
salve
sei stato tu che ha invaso la mia
caverna i miei fermato mentre stava
masturbando norme zio puoi farlo anche
se stessa di una caverna devo andare
indietro bene è stata ed è una bella
trama comunque dove stiamo andando
ci manca solo che spiato perché non
riesco a superare una collinetta dopo il
tuffo casinò sarebbe farebbe veramente
ridere ragazzi
tara evan ross web franca è stato molto
carino a noi atp spesso zio perché
escono bella roba
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi quindi
ho fatto dei livelli molto più figli del
solito perché ogni tanto faccio questi
micro speciali di happy wings perché
merita non sa questi livelli schiacciate
il tasto iscriviti e la campanellina
piccola che trovate vicino a tasti
iscriviti pisa meno rimanete aggiornati
sono i video che escono come sempre
vicini e ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
video birds
[Musica]